contracts, stood execution, reflection, but from my point of view, those three things stand out as the big ticket items. Whichever features of C++ are supported by the compiler I'm currently using at work. And if you're using Clang or one of the versions of Clang, Clang actually does a lot of backporting of later C++ features to earlier C++ versions. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 280, recorded on March 30th, 20206. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Ben, we chat about the big features shipping in C++26, GCC versus Klang, and more. All right, we're back.
contracts, stood execution, reflection, but from my point of view, those three things stand out as the big ticket items. Whichever features of C++ are supported by the compiler I'm currently using at work. And if you're using Clang or one of the versions of Clang, Clang actually does a lot of backporting of later C++ features to earlier C++ versions. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 280, recorded on March 30th, 20206. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Ben, we chat about the big features shipping in C++26, GCC versus Klang, and more. All right, we're back.|||contracts, stood execution, reflection, but from my point of view, those three things stand out as the big ticket items. Whichever features of C++ are supported by the compiler I'm currently using at work. And if you're using Clang or one of the versions of Clang, Clang actually does a lot of backporting of later C++ features to earlier C++ versions. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 280, recorded on March 30th, 20206. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Ben, we chat about the big features shipping in C++26, GCC versus Klang, and more. All right, we're back.
And how's it going? I mean, we were just chatting for 30 minutes, but we can pretend that we're doing this fresh. Spring is here, although we never really had a proper winter here in Denver. It's been very warm. You didn't have a... Everywhere else in, like, northeastern America was blizzarding for months, no? Well, not there in Denver.
And how's it going? I mean, we were just chatting for 30 minutes, but we can pretend that we're doing this fresh. Spring is here, although we never really had a proper winter here in Denver. It's been very warm. You didn't have a... Everywhere else in, like, northeastern America was blizzarding for months, no? Well, not there in Denver.|||最近怎么样？我的意思是，我们刚聊了30分钟，但我们可以假装这是刚开始。春天来了，尽管我们在丹佛其实没过上一个像样的冬天。天气一直很暖和。你们没有……比如美国东北部的其他地方不是连续几个月都在下暴风雪吗，不是吗？好吧，丹佛可没有。
We had a couple... We had a few inches of snow a couple of times, but no, I mean, it's 25 degrees out. Wow. Celsius. Wow. Are you kidding me? That makes me very sad.
We had a couple... We had a few inches of snow a couple of times, but no, I mean, it's 25 degrees out. Wow. Celsius. Wow. Are you kidding me? That makes me very sad.|||我们有过几次……下了几英寸的雪，但没有，我是说，外面有25度。哇。摄氏度。哇。你在开玩笑吗？这让我很难过。
I mean... Yeah, or even more. Yeah. All right. Some days. The running community in Denver must be thrilled because there's a lot of professional runners that live in the area there because of the altitude.
I mean... Yeah, or even more. Yeah. All right. Some days. The running community in Denver must be thrilled because there's a lot of professional runners that live in the area there because of the altitude.|||我是说……对，甚至更高。对。好吧。有些日子是这样。丹佛的跑步爱好者群体一定兴奋极了，因为那里海拔高，有很多职业跑步运动员住在那个地区。
Yeah, there's a lot of trail running. I don't know how it is up in the mountains. I mean, the mountains have had snow. It hasn't been super cold, though, so maybe it's been more wet. I'm not sure. Interesting. All right, well, hopefully that weather will make its way up to Canada and Toronto in the future because we had a brutal, just brutal winter.
Yeah, there's a lot of trail running. I don't know how it is up in the mountains. I mean, the mountains have had snow. It hasn't been super cold, though, so maybe it's been more wet. I'm not sure. Interesting. All right, well, hopefully that weather will make its way up to Canada and Toronto in the future because we had a brutal, just brutal winter.|||对，有很多越野跑。我不知道山上的情况怎么样。我是说，山上是下过雪。不过并没有超级冷，所以可能更湿润一些。我也不确定。有意思。好吧，希望这种天气以后能蔓延到加拿大和多伦多，因为我们经历了一个残酷的、简直残酷的冬天。
The worst winner, maybe since I've been in Toronto. Okay. Yeah, yeah. It was minus. I think we talked about that last time. Yeah, it was snowy out last time, I think. And it was like minus, what are we going to say, minus 15, minus 20, something. Yeah, I mean, there was a couple week period where the highest it got was minus 7 Celsius.
The worst winner, maybe since I've been in Toronto. Okay. Yeah, yeah. It was minus. I think we talked about that last time. Yeah, it was snowy out last time, I think. And it was like minus, what are we going to say, minus 15, minus 20, something. Yeah, I mean, there was a couple week period where the highest it got was minus 7 Celsius.|||最糟糕的冬天，也许自我来到多伦多以来是这样的。好的。对，对。气温是零下。我想我们上次聊过这个。对，我记得上次外面下雪了。气温大概是零下，我们要怎么说呢，零下15度，零下20度左右。对，我是说，有连续几周的时间，最高气温也只有零下7摄氏度。
But most of the time it was, yeah, minus 15, minus 20. But yeah, today, today there's no, I mean, I can see a tiny little bit of snow on my neighbor's lawn. But I was out in the backyard raking leaves this morning because, It's supposed to rain later and I'm hoping the rain will make the grass start to grow. I don't really know how it works, but I think the grass needs water. And so hopefully this is the end, no more snow. And I guess spring, when does spring start? A couple weeks ago.
But most of the time it was, yeah, minus 15, minus 20. But yeah, today, today there's no, I mean, I can see a tiny little bit of snow on my neighbor's lawn. But I was out in the backyard raking leaves this morning because, It's supposed to rain later and I'm hoping the rain will make the grass start to grow. I don't really know how it works, but I think the grass needs water. And so hopefully this is the end, no more snow. And I guess spring, when does spring start? A couple weeks ago.|||但大多数时候，是的，零下15度，零下20度。不过今天，今天没有，我是说，我能看到邻居的草坪上有一点点雪。但我今天早上在后院扫树叶，因为……待会儿好像要下雨，我希望雨能让草开始生长。我不太清楚这是怎么运作的，但我认为草需要水。所以希望这是结束，再也没有雪了。我想春天，春天是什么时候开始的？几周前。
The spring equinox was March 21st. Okay, so that's what. Whether you say that's when spring starts, I think depends. Right. We could say that. Yeah, spring equinox is, well, the moment of equinox, I don't know, It might have been, sometimes it's the 20th, but it's the 21st, more or less. The Catholic Church defines it as 21st of March, no matter when, no matter where the sun is.
The spring equinox was March 21st. Okay, so that's what. Whether you say that's when spring starts, I think depends. Right. We could say that. Yeah, spring equinox is, well, the moment of equinox, I don't know, It might have been, sometimes it's the 20th, but it's the 21st, more or less. The Catholic Church defines it as 21st of March, no matter when, no matter where the sun is.|||春分是3月21日。好吧，那就是……至于你是否说那是春分开始的时候，我觉得这因人而异。对。我们可以这么说。对，春分是，嗯，春分的时刻，我不知道，可能是，有时是20日，但差不多是21日。天主教会将其定义为3月21日，不管什么时候，不管太阳在哪里。
For the purposes of calculating Easter, that's the definition of Easter. Yes, which is around the corner now. Good Friday coming up. Which I had forgot was a holiday. Is it a holiday in the States? In general, no. Although, if you work in finance, the New York Stock Exchange is closed, that. day, so it generally is.
For the purposes of calculating Easter, that's the definition of Easter. Yes, which is around the corner now. Good Friday coming up. Which I had forgot was a holiday. Is it a holiday in the States? In general, no. Although, if you work in finance, the New York Stock Exchange is closed, that. day, so it generally is.|||为了计算复活节的目的，这就是复活节的定义。是的，复活节现在就在眼前了。耶稣受难日即将来临。我都忘了这是一个节日。在美国这也是个节日吗？一般来说，不是。不过，如果你在金融行业工作，纽约证券交易所那天会休市，所以通常算是。
Interesting. But for most people, I think, no. Interesting. So it depends. Depends on the country. Which I guess makes sense. Anyways, what are we chatting about today? I mean, I sent a couple topics, but I also said, if you've got stuff you want to chat about.
Interesting. But for most people, I think, no. Interesting. So it depends. Depends on the country. Which I guess makes sense. Anyways, what are we chatting about today? I mean, I sent a couple topics, but I also said, if you've got stuff you want to chat about.|||有意思。但对大多数人来说，我想，并不是。有意思。所以这要看情况。取决于国家。我想这也说得通。不管怎样，我们今天聊点什么？我的意思是，我发了几个话题，但我也说过，如果你有什么想聊的。
Yeah, I don't know. I don't know why I have. I don't really have much. Since we last talk, I've just been working, doing the normal grind. I don't know that I've been geeking out on algorithms, data structures, and programs very much. Yeah. Have you,
Yeah, I don't know. I don't know why I have. I don't really have much. Since we last talk, I've just been working, doing the normal grind. I don't know that I've been geeking out on algorithms, data structures, and programs very much. Yeah. Have you,|||是的，我不知道。我不知道为什么我有。我其实没什么可说的。自从我们上次谈话以来，我一直在工作，过着日常的枯燥生活。我不知道自己最近有没有对算法、数据结构和程序表现得非常狂热。是的。你有吗？
I don't really follow it too closely anymore. Do you, because I know that the one of the C++ ISO meetings, I think it was being held Oh yeah. Outside of London.
I don't really follow it too closely anymore. Do you, because I know that the one of the C++ ISO meetings, I think it was being held Oh yeah. Outside of London.|||我不再怎么密切关注了。你呢，因为我知道C++ ISO的其中一次会议，我想是在举行，哦，对了。伦敦郊外。
It was in Croydon. Croydon, yeah. This last week. Have you, do you pay attention to the papers or anything like that? I always skim over the papers when they,
It was in Croydon. Croydon, yeah. This last week. Have you, do you pay attention to the papers or anything like that? I always skim over the papers when they,|||是在克罗伊登。克罗伊登，对。就在上周。你，你会关注论文之类的内容吗？当论文发布时，我总是大致浏览一下。
when they go out in the monthly mailings. It's been fairly quiet lately because all the push has been Zipluplus 26, and everything for C++ plus 26 has been, has been pretty much designed for a year or more now. And so the last few mailings haven't been much new and exciting as much as just little bits here and there. But now that I think C++ plus 26 is done,
when they go out in the monthly mailings. It's been fairly quiet lately because all the push has been Zipluplus 26, and everything for C++ plus 26 has been, has been pretty much designed for a year or more now. And so the last few mailings haven't been much new and exciting as much as just little bits here and there. But now that I think C++ plus 26 is done,|||在每月的邮件中发送时。最近相当安静，因为所有的推进重心都在C++26上，而关于C++26的一切，实际上在一年多以前就基本上已经设计好了。所以过去几期的邮件里并没有太多新鲜刺激的内容，大多只是一些零零碎碎的小改动。但现在我认为C++26已经完成了，
just awaiting final approval from the national bodies, I think. And I think C++ plus 29 will start to see new and exciting things destined for C++ plus 29 there. Okay. I mean, I knew that C++ plus 26 had kind of, I was one of the two, one or two previous meetings. That was the one where they were like finalizing. It was the last moment to kind of ship things in. And so now they're in the ironing out the bugs and whatnot. Yeah.
just awaiting final approval from the national bodies, I think. And I think C++ plus 29 will start to see new and exciting things destined for C++ plus 29 there. Okay. I mean, I knew that C++ plus 26 had kind of, I was one of the two, one or two previous meetings. That was the one where they were like finalizing. It was the last moment to kind of ship things in. And so now they're in the ironing out the bugs and whatnot. Yeah.|||我想现在正等待各国国家机构的最终批准。我觉得在C++29中，我们将开始看到注定要加入C++29的新鲜且令人兴奋的东西。好吧。我的意思是，我知道C++26已经有点……我参加了前两次会议中的一次。那是他们正在敲定细节的会议。那是把东西塞进去的最后一个时刻。所以现在他们正处于修复错误之类的阶段。是的。
Yeah. So it has, it has contracts. It has stood execution. So contracts actually ended. So contracts actually ended up making, I heard there was a bunch of kerfuffle. Contracts are officially in the draft. At this point, I think we're past the point where they can be taken out, at least. If C++ plus 26 were to have sustained national body voting against it or enough national bodies voting against it,
Yeah. So it has, it has contracts. It has stood execution. So contracts actually ended. So contracts actually ended up making, I heard there was a bunch of kerfuffle. Contracts are officially in the draft. At this point, I think we're past the point where they can be taken out, at least. If C++ plus 26 were to have sustained national body voting against it or enough national bodies voting against it,|||对。所以它有，它有契约（contracts）。它有std::execution。所以契约实际上最终……我听说引发了一阵骚动。契约已经正式进入了草案中。在这一点上，我认为我们已经过了可以将其移除的阶段，至少如此。如果C++26遭到国家机构持续的反对投票，或者有足够多的国家机构投票反对它，
that it basically C++ plus 26 wouldn't ship. it's not the case that votes can now take contracts out of C++26. It's just the case that votes can, in theory, prevent C++26 from shipping. I see. But I don't think that's probably going to happen. Firstly, because there are a lot more national bodies these days than they used to be. Like back in the day, the number of national bodies in the C++ plus I-side process was less than 10. and now it's, I don't know, it's 20 something, right?
that it basically C++ plus 26 wouldn't ship. it's not the case that votes can now take contracts out of C++26. It's just the case that votes can, in theory, prevent C++26 from shipping. I see. But I don't think that's probably going to happen. Firstly, because there are a lot more national bodies these days than they used to be. Like back in the day, the number of national bodies in the C++ plus I-side process was less than 10. and now it's, I don't know, it's 20 something, right?|||那么基本上C++26就不会发布了。现在的情况并不是说通过投票就能把契约从C++26中剔除。只是说理论上投票可以阻止C++26的发布。原来如此。但我认为这大概不会发生。首先，因为现在的国家机构比过去多得多。就像过去一样，在C++ ISO流程中的国家机构数量不到10个，而现在，我不知道，有20多个了，对吧？
So in order to block C-Clubs off 26, I think you'd have to have more than a third no votes, right? And that seems unlikely at this point. Okay, yeah, that makes sense. And I guess the reason I thought that there was kerfuffle, I mean, there was, but it was actually kerfuffle from the quote-unquote past because I watched in the last couple weeks, or maybe it was a month ago, the panel, the eye, ISO committee panel from CPPON, which happened back in September, but only got released in the last, whatever, whenever I watched it, within the last month, we'll say. And there was quite a bit of back and forth between panel members of, you know, contracts this and contracts that.
So in order to block C-Clubs off 26, I think you'd have to have more than a third no votes, right? And that seems unlikely at this point. Okay, yeah, that makes sense. And I guess the reason I thought that there was kerfuffle, I mean, there was, but it was actually kerfuffle from the quote-unquote past because I watched in the last couple weeks, or maybe it was a month ago, the panel, the eye, ISO committee panel from CPPON, which happened back in September, but only got released in the last, whatever, whenever I watched it, within the last month, we'll say. And there was quite a bit of back and forth between panel members of, you know, contracts this and contracts that.|||所以要想阻止C++26，我认为你必须获得超过三分之一的反对票，对吧？就目前来看，这似乎不太可能。好吧，是的，这说得通。我想我以为有骚动的原因——我的确有，但实际上那是来自所谓过去的骚动，因为我在过去几周（或者可能是一个月前）观看了小组讨论，那是来自CPPCON的ISO委员会小组讨论，该讨论发生在去年9月，但直到最近——不管怎样，反正是在我观看的时候，也就是最近一个月内才发布。小组成员之间有很多关于“契约这个”和“契约那个”的来回辩论。
Yeah, there are definitely folks who have had sustained opposition to contracts for various reasons. There have been papers that argued for and against. procedurally, I think, you know, what happened was what was meant to happen, which is that the national body comments got addressed. That doesn't necessarily mean that everything got, quote, fixed to make everyone happy and everything sunshine and roses, but it means what it means. There is a procedure for addressing these things.
Yeah, there are definitely folks who have had sustained opposition to contracts for various reasons. There have been papers that argued for and against. procedurally, I think, you, what happened was what was meant to happen, which is that the national body comments got addressed. That doesn't necessarily mean that everything got, quote, fixed to make everyone happy and everything sunshine and roses, but it means what it means. There is a procedure for addressing these things.|||是的，确实有些人出于各种原因对契约持持续反对态度。曾有过支持和反对的论文。在程序上，我认为，发生的事情正是应该发生的事情，也就是国家机构的意见得到了处理。这并不一定意味着所有事情都“修复”到了让每个人都满意、一切都阳光灿烂的程度，但它就是这个意思。处理这些事情是有既定程序的。
Not that I'm any expert, by the way. You should not be listening to me for an expert on these things. But from what I've heard, you know, the procedure played out as the ISO procedure does. And now, now here we are. Yeah. And C++26, I would expect to receive enough national body approvals to become the next ISO standard. Yeah, as it always does. I mean, it would be very surprising if it didn't.
Not that I'm any expert, by the way. You should not be listening to me for an expert on these things. But from what I've heard, you know, the procedure played out as the ISO procedure does. And now, now here we are. Yeah. And C++26, I would expect to receive enough national body approvals to become the next ISO standard. Yeah, as it always does. I mean, it would be very surprising if it didn't.|||顺便说一句，我可不是什么专家。你不应该把我当成这些事情的专家来听。但据我所听到的，你知道，这个程序正如ISO程序那样展开了。现在，我们就在这里了。是的。对于C++26，我预计它会获得足够的国家机构批准，成为下一个ISO标准。是的，一如既往。我的意思是，如果没有的话那才叫大吃一惊呢。
But yes, I interrupted you. So you started enumerating C++26 thing. And then I said, wait, contracts. That got in? And then I think you had mentioned stood execution. And then that's when I interrupted you. Reflection. Reflection.
But yes, I interrupted you. So you started enumerating C++26 thing. And then I said, wait, contracts. That got in? And then I think you had mentioned stood execution. And then that's when I interrupted you. Reflection. Reflection.|||不过是的，我打断了你。所以你开始列举C++26的东西。然后我说，等等，契约。这被收录进去了？然后我想你提到了std::execution。接着我就打断了你。反射。反射。
Yeah, I was trying to think through the big ticket items. And I think contracts stood execution, reflection. There's a bunch of other things, of course. But from my point of view, those three things stand out as the big ticket items. Are you in the Jason Turner camp of waiting until these things show up actually to be used before you start taking them for a spin? or are you on the compiler, explorer, forks of clang where it's got some pre-implemented version and you've played with reflection already?
Yeah, I was trying to think through the big ticket items. And I think contracts stood execution, reflection. There's a bunch of other things, of course. But from my point of view, those three things stand out as the big ticket items. Are you in the Jason Turner camp of waiting until these things show up actually to be used before you start taking them for a spin? or are you on the compiler, explorer, forks of clang where it's got some pre-implemented version and you've played with reflection already?|||是的，我当时在努力梳理那些重磅项目。我认为是契约、std::execution、反射。当然还有一堆其他东西。但从我的角度来看，这三样东西作为重磅项目最为突出。你是属于Jason Turner阵营，等到这些东西真正出现并可以投入使用时才开始尝鲜呢？还是属于那种使用Compiler Explorer上带有某些预实现版本的Clang分支，并且已经玩过反射的人？
Generally, I haven't really played with reflection. So I'm more forward-looking than Jason. Well, Jason, you know, is a trainer. He has to deal with. He has to be very precise about knowing the differences between all the versions of C++. Because, you know, he'll go to a place and train them and they're able only to use C++ plus 20 and not yet C++ plus 23, for instance.
Generally, I haven't really played with reflection. So I'm more forward-looking than Jason. Well, Jason, you know, is a trainer. He has to deal with. He has to be very precise about knowing the differences between all the versions of C++. Because, you know, he'll go to a place and train them and they're able only to use C++ plus 20 and not yet C++ plus 23, for instance.|||一般来说，我其实并没有玩过反射。所以我的眼光比Jason更前瞻一些。嗯，你知道，Jason是一位培训师。他必须处理。他必须非常准确地了解C++所有版本之间的区别。因为，你知道，他会去某个地方培训他们，而他们可能只能使用C++20，而还不能使用C++23，比如说。
So he has situations like that. So I guess I'm a little more fast and loose. I tend to use not, my usages tend to be not driven by a standard version, but by what the compiler I use supports. Right. So it's not the case that I'm on C++ plus 20 or I'm on C++ plus 23. No, I'm on whichever features of C++ plus are supported by, the compiler I'm currently using at work.
So he has situations like that. So I guess I'm a little more fast and loose. I tend to use not, my usages tend to be not driven by a standard version, but by what the compiler I use supports. Right. So it's not the case that I'm on C++ plus 20 or I'm on C++ plus 23. No, I'm on whichever features of C++ are supported by, the compiler I'm currently using at work.|||所以他会遇到这种情况。所以我想我可能稍微随性一些。我的使用倾向往往不是由标准版本驱动的，而是由我使用的编译器所支持的功能驱动的。对。所以并不是说我处在C++20或者C++23。不，我是支持我目前在工作中使用的编译器所支持的任何C++特性。
And if you're using Clang, or one of the versions of Clang, Clang actually does a lot of backporting of later C++ features to earlier C++ versions, because they take the view that if the compiler supports it, we'll put it under a feature macro, and it'll be available. even if you say you want C++ plus 20, if the compiler supports the feature of, let's say, destructuring a pack. What was it?
And if you're using Clang, or one of the versions of Clang, Clang actually does a lot of backporting of later C++ features to earlier C++ versions, because they take the view that if the compiler supports it, we'll put it under a feature macro, and it'll be available. even if you say you want C++ plus 20, if the compiler supports the feature of, let's say, destructuring a pack. What was it?|||如果你使用的是Clang，或者Clang的某个版本，Clang实际上会将许多较晚的C++特性向后移植（backporting）到较早的C++版本中，因为他们的观点是，如果编译器支持它，我们就把它放在一个特性宏（feature macro）下面，这样它就可以使用了。即使你说你想要C++20，如果编译器支持某种特性，比如解构参数包（destructuring a pack）。那是什么来着？
Destructuring, yeah, structure blindings can introduce a pack, is the one I'm thinking of, right? That feature exists in the latest versions of Clang. They will quite happily compile code that uses that feature, even if you ask for C++20. So, you know, as a library author, I sort of find myself, always in this sort of halfway house between standard
Destructuring, yeah, structure blindings can introduce a pack, is the one I'm thinking of, right? That feature exists in the latest versions of Clang. They will quite happily compile code that uses that feature, even if you ask for C++20. So, you know, as a library author, I sort of find myself, always in this sort of halfway house between standard|||解构，是的，结构化绑定可以引入参数包，这就是我所想的，对吧？这个特性存在于Clang的最新版本中。即使你要求使用C++20，他们也会非常乐意编译使用该特性的代码。所以，你知道，作为一名库作者，我发现自己总是处于这种标准之间的半途状态……
versions, particularly supporting Clang, I am anyway. With GCC I think they take a different view, which is like, if you ask for C++ 20, that's what you get. That feature, although it exists, although the compiler can support it, if you ask for a later version, if you ask for 20, you're not getting it.
versions, particularly supporting Clang, I am anyway. With GCC I think they take a different view, which is like, if you ask for C++ 20, that's what you get. That feature, although it exists, although the compiler can support it, if you ask for a later version, if you ask for 20, you're not getting it.|||版本，特别是支持Clang，我反正是这样的。对于GCC，我认为他们持不同的观点，那就是：如果你要求C++20，你得到的就只有这些。那个特性虽然存在，虽然编译器能够支持它，但如果你要求的是一个较晚的版本，如果你要求的是20，你是拿不到它的。
Whereas Clang does the more granular feature backporting. Yeah, it's really interesting. And so the newer features, are they all behind a feature macro or sometimes are they just there? Since C++20, the newer features have tended to be put behind feature macros. Which is, you know, I, again, as a library writer, I tend to try to,
Whereas Clang does the more granular feature backporting. Yeah, it's really interesting. And so the newer features, are they all behind a feature macro or sometimes are they just there? Since C++20, the newer features have tended to be put behind feature macros. Which is, you know, I, again, as a library writer, I tend to try to,|||而Clang则做了更细颗粒度的特性向后移植。是的，这真的很有趣。那么这些较新的特性，它们是否都在特性宏的后面，还是有时直接就放在那里？自C++20以来，较新的特性往往都被放在了特性宏后面。你知道的，作为一名库编写者，我倾向于尝试……
I use those where they are useful sometimes, but I don't like to litter the code with if-defs. You know, you don't really want that either. They're an eyesore, if you can avoid them. It makes it difficult. It can make it difficult. But sometimes the features are useful enough that in a particular situation you want to say, oh, actually, if this feature is available, it's going to be easier. It's going to make this code easy to understand and probably faster to compile.
I use those where they are useful sometimes, but I don't like to litter the code with if-defs. You don't really want that either. They're an eyesore, if you can avoid them. It makes it difficult. It can make it difficult. But sometimes the features are useful enough that in a particular situation you want to say, oh, actually, if this feature is available, it's going to be easier. It's going to make this code easy to understand and probably faster to compile.|||我有时会在它们有用的时候使用它们，但我不太喜欢在代码里到处充斥着 `#if-def`。你其实也不希望这样。如果能避免的话，它们简直是眼中钉。这会增加难度。这确实会增加难度。但有时这些特性非常有用，以至于在特定情况下你会想说：“哦，实际上，如果这个特性可用，事情就会变得更容易。”它会让这段代码更容易理解，而且编译速度可能会更快。
Yeah, it's been a while since I was in a heavy C++ code base, but one of the first companies I worked for, or the first company I worked for out of school, arguably abused the feature and they had a ton of different what they called modules without giving away too much whatever insider info and so you would you would have constantly these you know if ding ding ding and it would be or or or and i remember i'm trying to design a bunch of stuff where you would kind of hide the module specific stuff and some function below and so i could just write generic code at a level without because you'd hit some pieces of the code where it would be brutal.
Yeah, it's been a while since I was in a heavy C++ code base, but one of the first companies I worked for, or the first company I worked for out of school, arguably abused the feature and they had a ton of different what they called modules without giving away too much whatever insider info and so you would you would have constantly these you know if ding ding ding and it would be or or or and i remember i'm trying to design a bunch of stuff where you would kind of hide the module specific stuff and some function below and so i could just write generic code at a level without because you'd hit some pieces of the code where it would be brutal.|||是的，我已经很久没有接触庞大的C++代码库了，但我刚毕业时工作的公司之一（或者说第一家公司），可以说滥用了这个特性，他们有大量不同的所谓模块——在不透露太多内部消息的前提下——所以你会经常看到这些，你知道的，`if` 叮叮叮，然后是 `or` 或者 `or`，我记得我当时试图设计一堆东西，把特定于模块的东西隐藏在下面的一些函数中，这样我就可以在某个层面上编写通用的代码，而不必去碰那些极其残酷的代码片段。
You'd have like interleaved macros, like future macros and and like if statements. And so like you'd have if, but then inside the block of the if, you'd have the different macros because you'd have different settings. Oh, wow. And it was, it could very quickly get unwieldly, if that's the correct word. Anyways, yeah. But I mean, used in judiciously, they can be very useful. Yeah.
You'd have like interleaved macros, like future macros and and like if statements. And so like you'd have if, but then inside the block of the if, you'd have the different macros because you'd have different settings. Oh, and it was, it could very quickly get unwieldly, if that's the correct word. Anyways, yeah. But I mean, used in judiciously, they can be very useful. Yeah.|||你会遇到像交织在一起的宏，比如特性宏和 `if` 语句。所以就像你会有一个 `if`，但在 `if` 块的内部，你会有不同的宏，因为你有不同的设置。哦，如果用“笨拙”这个词来形容的话，它会迅速变得难以掌控。不管怎样，是的。不过我的意思是，如果明智地使用它们，它们会非常有用。是的。
Yeah. I guess you could say that about a lot of language features, though. you know, if you use it prudently and it's great, but you can always abuse some language feature. Yes, maybe especially when it comes to C++. Yeah. And, you know, C++ is famous for being a large language and having dark corners and everyone using a sort of slightly different subset of that language according to policy. Yeah.
Yeah. I guess you could say that about a lot of language features, though. you know, if you use it prudently and it's great, but you can always abuse some language feature. Yes, maybe especially when it comes to C++. Yeah. And, you0 know, C++ is famous for being a large language and having dark corners and everyone using a sort of slightly different subset of that language according to policy. Yeah.|||是的。不过我想对许多语言特性都可以这么说。你知道，如果你谨慎地使用它，那就很棒，但你总能滥用某些语言特性。是的，也许特别是对于C++而言。是的。而且，你知道，C++以庞大、拥有黑暗角落而闻名，每个人都根据规范使用该语言的一种略有不同的子集。是的。
But, you know, like Kate said, it's complicated. Did you see that talk of hers? It's from now it's from pre-pandemic. So it's old now, I guess. But she said in that talk, yeah, it's complicated. You do have to know how your language works. And in the sense, there is no royal road to knowing C++. You just, you'd have to know the language.
But, you know, like Kate said, it's complicated. Did you see that talk of hers? It's from now it's from pre-pandemic. So it's old now, I guess. But she said in that talk, yeah, it's complicated. You do have to know how your language works. And in the sense, there is no royal road to knowing C++. You just, you'd have to know the language.|||但是，你知道，就像Kate说的，这很复杂。你看过她的那场演讲吗？那是疫情前的了。所以现在算很旧了，我想。但她在演讲中说过，是的，这很复杂。你确实必须了解你的语言是如何工作的。从某种意义上说，了解C++没有捷径。你只是，你必须了解这门语言。
Yeah. And the libraries. Yeah, I can't remember who said it, but I mean, I'm sure several people have. But there's essentially like seven different languages within C++. Oh, yeah, in terms of like, cheering completeness. I'm like, maybe we're up to seven now.
Yeah. And the libraries. Yeah, I can't remember who said it, but I mean, I'm sure several people have. But there's essentially like seven different languages within C++. Oh, yeah, in terms of like, cheering completeness. I'm like, maybe we're up to seven now.|||是的。还有库。是的，我不记得是谁说的了，但我相信不止一个人说过。但C++内部本质上有大约七种不同的语言。哦，是的，就图灵完备性而言。我觉得，也许我们现在已经达到七种了。
Yeah. But yes. Plus or minus. And I can't remember what podcast I was listening to recently. It might have been the Haskell podcast or the Haskell something. And they were talking about touring complete languages and like the type system and how that's just like a terrible idea. And yes, they're like, they didn't refer to C++ by name, but they said like the fact
Yeah. But yes. Plus or minus. And I can't remember what podcast I was listening to recently. It might have been the Haskell podcast or the Haskell something. And they were talking about touring complete languages and like the type system and how that's just like a terrible idea. And yes, they're like, they didn't refer to C++ by name, but they said like the fact|||是的。差不多吧。我不记得最近听的是哪个播客了。可能是Haskell播客或Haskell相关的节目。他们谈到了图灵完备语言以及类型系统，并说这简直是个糟糕的主意。是的，他们说，虽然没有点名C++，但他们说，事实是……
that it exists and you can do powerful things with it does not make it like a good thing. And there are better alternatives where you aren't, you know, computing factorials at compile time in this kind of... Sure. Anyways. And they didn't mention C++ and I was like, I know what language you're talking about. I kind of agree, but also, you know, as a professional C++ library writer, that stuff is really useful, but I sort of agree in a platonic sense, you know,
that it exists and you can do powerful things with it does not make it like a good thing. And there are better alternatives where you aren't, you know, computing factorials at compile time in this kind of... Sure. Anyways. And they didn't mention C++ and I was like, I know what language you're talking about. I kind of agree, but also, you know, as a professional C++ library writer, that stuff is really useful, but I sort of agree in a platonic sense, you know,|||它存在并且你可以用它做强大事情的事实，并不意味着它是一件好事。还有更好的替代方案，在那里你不会——你知道的——在编译时计算阶乘……当然。不管怎样。他们没有提到C++，而我想：我知道你在说哪门语言。我有点赞同，但同时，作为一名专业的C++库编写者，那些东西确实很有用，但我从柏拉图式的意义上讲也部分赞同，你知道的，
if you have, if your language is cheering complete, you know, and I gave a lightly talk about this, what you're saying is, it's fine for my language to have footguns, right? Infinite recursion. Chearing completeness means effectively infinite recursion is okay.
if you have, if your language is cheering complete, you know, and I gave a lightly talk about this, what you're saying is, it's fine for my language to have footguns, right? Infinite recursion. Chearing completeness means effectively infinite recursion is okay.|||如果你有，如果你的语言是图灵完备的，你知道的，我曾就此做过一次轻松的演讲，你所说的是，我的语言有“脚枪”（footguns，指容易误伤自己的设计）是可以接受的，对吧？无限递归。图灵完备意味着实际上无限递归是可以接受的。
You know, you get, one of the ways you get your incompleteness is through self-reference, right? And so that opens the door to infinite loops, infinite recurrence, infinite recursion, et cetera. Whereas if you have a type system which cannot express that kind of self-reference, you still have a nice structural type system.
You know, you get, one of the ways you get your incompleteness is through self-reference, right? And so that opens the door to infinite loops, infinite recurrence, infinite recursion, et cetera. Whereas if you have a type system which cannot express that kind of self-reference, you still have a nice structural type system.|||你知道，你得到的，获得不完整性（注：此处原文可能口误为 incompleteness，实指 Turing completeness 或不完备）的方法之一就是通过自指（self-reference），对吧？这就为无限循环、无限重复、无限递归等打开了大门。而如果你有一个无法表达这种自指的类型系统，你依然拥有一个不错的结构化类型系统。
You still can do iteration, recursion. You just can't make it unbounded. So you get some kind of guarantees. Right. I'm of two minds about it. I won't remember his name, but when I was in California, I was at a meetup and there was a guy working at Facebook or meta, I guess now. At the time, I think it was Facebook.
You still can do iteration, recursion. You just can't make it unbounded. So you get some kind of guarantees. Right. I'm of two minds about it. I won't remember his name, but when I was in California, I was at a meetup and there was a guy working at Facebook or meta, I guess now. At the time, I think it was Facebook.|||你仍然可以做迭代、递归。你只是不能让它无界。所以你会得到某种保证。对。对此我抱有两种态度。我不记得他的名字了，但当我在加利福尼亚时，我参加了一个聚会，那里有一个在Facebook（现在我想叫Meta）工作的人。当时，我认为那是Facebook。
And he said when he codes on his own, he codes in C++, because he doesn't have to worry about other people because he knows what he's doing. But he's like, as a manager of a team, I prefer Rust because I can sleep better at night. And there's less for me to worry about. He's like, I still prefer personally C++ because I have more freedom and I trust myself. But when I'm managing a team, I would prefer the language that comes with more guardrails. It doesn't mean I'm going to sleep perfectly at night. I still have stuff to worry about. But out of the box, it's, I think, for a team that consists of newer programmers and some, I'm sure, more experienced.
And he said when he codes on his own, he codes in C++, because he doesn't have to worry about other people because he knows what he's doing. But he's like, as a manager of a team, I prefer Rust because I can sleep better at night. And there's less for me to worry about. He's like, I still prefer personally C++ because I have more freedom and I trust myself. But when I'm managing a team, I would prefer the language that comes with more guardrails. It doesn't mean I'm going to sleep perfectly at night. I still have stuff to worry about. But out of the box, it's, I think, for a team that consists of newer programmers and some, I'm sure, more experienced.|||他说当他自己写代码时，他用C++编写，因为他不必担心其他人，他知道自己在做什么。但他觉得，作为团队的管理者，我更喜欢Rust，因为这样我晚上能睡得更好。需要我操心的事情更少。他说：我个人仍然更喜欢C++，因为我有更多的自由，而且我相信自己。但当我在管理团队时，我会更倾向于选择带有更多护栏（guardrails）的语言。这并不意味着我晚上就能完全安睡。我依然有事情要操心。但开箱即用的是，我认为，对于一个由较年轻的程序员以及一些经验丰富的程序员组成的团队来说……
But that's always stuck with me of him saying that he actually prefers C++, but not as a manager. Right. C++ 26 and 29, I haven't heard anything about 29. Have you heard any? The only thing I've heard was recently, Theus, hosting about the possibility. of targeting the Units Library for Zepla plus 29. Okay. That's the amalgamation.
That's always stuck with me of him saying that he actually prefers C++, but not as a manager. Right. C++ 26 and 29, I haven't heard anything about 29. Have you heard any? The only thing I've heard was recently, Theus, hosting about the possibility. of targeting the Units Library for Zepla plus 29. Okay. That's the amalgamation.|||他说的这句话一直让我印象深刻：他实际上更喜欢C++，但作为管理者则不然。对。C++26和29，我没听过任何关于29的消息。你听到过吗？我听到的唯一一件事是最近Theus在主持讨论将Units库作为C++29目标的可能性。好的。那是各种库的合并。
I know they put together like they united all the different factions of unit libraries and tried to bring them together to have one. It is a surprisingly complex space. There are many, many use cases. And most people have some idea about what they think a Units Library needs support, but I think for most people, certainly for me, you know, actually finding out about metrology, I think it is. I've never heard of that. It's the science of measurement, right? So there's all kinds of use cases that, you know, aren't obvious unless you start looking
I know they put together like they united all the different factions of unit libraries and tried to bring them together to have one. It is a surprisingly complex space. There are many, many use cases. And most people have some idea about what they think a Units Library needs support, but I think for most people, certainly for me, you know, actually finding out about metrology, I think it is. I've never heard of that. It's the science of measurement, right? So there's all kinds of use cases that, you know, aren't obvious unless you start looking|||我知道他们把不同的单位库派别联合起来，试图将它们合而为一。这是一个出乎意料复杂的领域。有非常多的用例。大多数人对于Units库需要支持什么都有一些想法，但我认为对大多数人来说，对我和我这样的人来说，你知道的，实际上去了解计量学（metrology）——我想就是这个。我从未听说过这个词。那是关于测量的科学，对吧？所以有各种各样的用例，你知道的，除非你开始深入研究，否则并不明显。
into these things. And yeah, the MP Units Library supports a lot of things, a lot of things. Yeah, I remember I remember when I went to committee meetings Seeing him present a few times And yeah, it's surprisingly deep space That is like an iceberg that Yes You see a couple examples
into these things. And yeah, the MP Units Library supports a lot of things, a lot of things. Yeah, I remember I remember when I went to committee meetings Seeing him present a few times And yeah, is surprisingly deep space That is like an iceberg that Yes You see a couple examples|||这些事情。是的，MP Units库支持很多东西，很多东西。是的，我记得当我参加委员会会议时，看到他做了几次展示，是的，这是一个出乎意料深奥的领域。这就像一座冰山，是的，你看到了几个例子，
And you're like, oh yeah, I get what that's for And then you see the iceberg that's underneath And there's a whole I can't remember if it's SIs Or there's like there's some like ISO community Or some body of that is deemed seven different things As like standard whatever Oh yeah
And you're like, oh yeah, I get what that's for And then you see the iceberg that's underneath And there's a whole I can't remember if it's SIs Or there's like there's some like ISO community Or some body of that is deemed seven different things As like standard whatever Oh yeah|||然后你会想：哦，是的，我明白那是用来做什么的了。接着你看到了下面的冰山，那里有整个——我不记得是SI制还是有某种ISO社区或某个机构被认为有七种不同的东西作为标准什么的。哦，是的，
the standard the S-I-units system and down the it's the yeah and so you you learned this in high school physics right I don't know
the standard the S-I-units system and down the it's the yeah and so you you learned this in high school physics right I don't know|||标准，SI单位系统，下面是——是的，所以你在高中物理里学过这个，对吧？我不知道。
I only took physics this is like the kilogram the meter the second the amp I think is in there those those are the base
I only took physics this is like the kilogram the meter the second the amp I think is in there those those are the base|||我只学过物理，这就像千克、米、秒，安培好像也在里面，那些是基础……
yeah the base units which are the amp is the strange one you think it's strange because it's two lumps per second right
yeah the base units which are the amp is the strange one you think it's strange because it's two lumps per second right|||是的，基础单位，其中安培是个奇怪的单位。你觉得它奇怪是因为它是每秒两个……对吧？
you think you might think that charge is the basic quantity, and so Qon would be the basic unit. But in the SI, it's actually the M. You've retained more from physics than I did, that's for sure. Okay, so that's C++. I mean, I feel like at some point we should bring someone who's still attending meetings.
you think you might think that charge is the basic quantity, and so Qon would be the basic unit. But in the SI, it's actually the M. You've retained more from physics than I did, that's for sure. Okay, so that's C++. I mean, I feel like at some point we should bring someone who's still attending meetings.|||你可能会认为电荷是基本量，所以库仑（Qon，注：口误或笔误应为 Coulomb）会是基本单位。但在SI中，实际上是M（注：应为安培 A）。你从物理中保留下来的知识比我多，那是肯定的。好吧，这就是C++。我的意思是，我觉得在某个时候我们应该请一位仍在参加会议的人来。
I know Barry is the most prolific author of papers and doing things that's been interviewed in the past. and Barry's certainly given good talks about reflection. Has he? I actually don't, the last Barry Revzen talk I've seen, I want to say was the like Ranges comparison one because he doesn't speak often. I think that actually was like the first talk that I've seen him give. He's been speaking more these last few years. I think he certainly gave a reflection talk which was very good at CPPCon.
I know Barry is the most prolific author of papers and doing things that's been interviewed in the past. and Barry's certainly given good talks about reflection. Has he? I actually don't, the last Barry Revzen talk I've seen, I want to say was the like Ranges comparison one because he doesn't speak often. I think that actually was like the first talk that I've seen him give. He's been speaking more these last few years. I think he certainly gave a reflection talk which was very good at CPPCon.|||我知道Barry是过去接受过采访的、最多产的论文作者和实干家。Barry当然做过关于反射的精彩演讲。是吗？我其实没有……我看到的最后一场Barry Revzen的演讲，我想应该是类似Ranges比较的那场，因为他很少发言。我认为那实际上是我看他做的第一场演讲。这几年他发言越来越多了。我想他在CPPCon上肯定做过一场非常棒的关于反射的演讲。
I think he recently repeated that talk or updated that talk for the Chicago meetup, and he's giving the opening keynote of C++ now, which is also about reflection, I believe. Okay, well, so yeah, I've Googled, I've YouTube, Barry Revzen, and the top two talks are the one that I mentioned, iterators and ranges, which compare C++ to D to Rust. And inside of it, he also mentions Java and Python. Right. He gave that a couple times, but the top one got posted one month ago. So there you go, YouTube. Sometimes you do well.
I think he recently repeated that talk or updated that talk for the Chicago meetup, and he's giving the opening keynote of C++ now, which is also about reflection, I believe. Okay, well, so yeah, I've Googled, I've YouTube, Barry Revzen, and the top two talks are the one that I mentioned, iterators and ranges, which compare C++ to D to Rust. And inside of it, he also mentions Java and Python. Right. He gave that a couple times, but the top one got posted one month ago. So there you go, YouTube. Sometimes you do well.|||我想他最近为芝加哥聚会重复或更新了那场演讲，而且他正在发表C++ Now大会的开幕主题演讲，这也是关于反射的，我相信。好吧，那么，是的，我谷歌过、在YouTube上搜过Barry Revzen，排名前两位的演讲就是我提到的那个——迭代器和范围（iterators and ranges），它将C++与D语言、Rust进行了比较。在其中，它还提到了Java和Python。是的。他讲过好几次，但排在第一位的那个是一个月前发布的。所以你看，YouTube。有时候你表现得不错。
Sometimes you do poorly. You did not recommend Barry's talk to me. And it's called Practical Reflection with C++-26. So we will link it in the show notes. And I will put it on my list of talks to watch. That's the problem. I always whine about how they've now trying to pander to the algorithm. So they bleed these things out for so long.
Sometimes you do poorly. You did not recommend Barry's talk to me. And it's called Practical Reflection with C++-26. So we will link it in the show notes. And I will put it on my list of talks to watch. That's the problem. I always whine about how they've now trying to pander to the algorithm. So they bleed these things out for so long.|||有时你表现得很差。你没有向我推荐Barry的演讲。它叫做《C++26实用反射》（Practical Reflection with C++-26）。所以我们会把它链接到节目shownotes中。我会把它加入我的待看演讲列表中。这就是问题所在。我总是抱怨他们现在如何试图迎合算法。所以他们把这些东西拖延了这么久才放出来。
And I used to just like, they used to just drop them all at once. and I would go and pick, create my own little playlist and then I'd watch them all like back to back to back. But now whenever we mention these, half the time I go and add it to the show notes and then it has to be unlinked. It's not,
and I used to just like, they used to just drop them all at once. and I would go and pick, create my own little playlist and then I'd watch them all like back to back to back. But now whenever we mention these, half the time I go and add it to the show notes and then it has to be unlinked. It's not,|||我以前很喜欢那种——他们过去是一次性把所有内容都放出来的。然后我会去挑选、创建我自己的小播放列表，接着我会连续不断地把它们看完。但现在每当我们提到这些时，有一半时间我去把它加到shownotes里，结果后来却发现链接失效了。它还没……
it's not out yet. But I will go and update that. All right. So that's like a mini C++ plus 26, 29. I mean, are there other things? Like, those are the three that you've mentioned, but.
it's not out yet. But I will go and update that. All right. So that's like a mini C++ plus 26, 29. I mean, are there other things? Like, those are the three that you've mentioned, but.|||还没发布。但我会去更新的。好的。所以这就像是一个迷你的C++26、29讨论。我的意思是，还有其他事情吗？比如，这是你提到的三点，但是……
Well, reflection is the big ticket item that most people are waiting for. I heard that one of the, the compilers had implemented already. That's right. Sorry, the GCC has the first implementation already emerged. Yeah, yeah. For about a month or so now, I think.
Well, reflection is the big ticket item that most people are waiting for. I heard that one of the, the compilers had implemented already. That's right. Sorry, the GCC has the first implementation already emerged. Yeah, yeah. For about a month or so now, I think.|||嗯，反射是大多数人在等待的重磅项目。我听说其中一个编译器已经实现了。没错。抱歉，GCC已经出现了第一个实现版本。对，对。大概有一个月左右了吧，我想。
So I guess it sounded like you were using Klang because... The Klang reflection fork has been on Compiler Explorer for a while now. And so when you see, oftentimes when you see examples, there'll be links using that. Okay. And so you're, I guess, just waiting for that. to be? Well, I won't be using reflection for a while yet in my day job. It is exciting. But what I'm far more excited about in the sense of being able to use it now and having been using it for the last couple of years is senders and receivers, which is not admittedly the
So I guess it sounded like you were using Klang because... The Klang reflection fork has been on Compiler Explorer for a while now. And so when you see, oftentimes when you see examples, there'll be links using that. Okay. And so you're, I guess, just waiting for that. to be? Well, I won't be using reflection for a while yet in my day job. It is exciting. But what I'm far more excited about in the sense of being able to use it now and having been using it for the last couple of years is senders and receivers, which is not admittedly the|||所以听起来你好像在用Clang，因为……Clang的反射分支在Compiler Explorer上已经有一段时间了。所以当你看到时，通常当你看到示例时，会有使用该分支的链接。好的。所以我猜你只是在等那个……被……？嗯，在我的日常工作中，我还不会在短时间内使用反射。这确实令人兴奋。但我更兴奋的是——就能够现在使用它以及在过去几年里一直在使用它而言——是senders and receivers（发送者和接收者），这固然不是……
standard version, but, you know, my implementation. And are you going to, are there is there going to be some big change that's going to switch when that's available to you? Because I know, that you have your implementation, are you going to be able to, like, merge the two somehow, or? Well, so I don't think that is, so that's not beyond the realm of possibility, but I don't think it's maybe going to be worth it for a while because, you know, my implementation targets their metal microcontrollers, targets zero exception, zero allocation environments. Now, the standard version is fairly zero, pretty much zero allocation, if you want. want that. But zero exception is the standard version obviously plays nicely with exceptions.
standard version, but, you know, my implementation. And are you going to, are there is there going to be some big change that's going to switch when that's available to you? Because I know, that you have your implementation, are you going to be able to, like, merge the two somehow, or? Well, so I don't think that is, so that's not beyond the realm of possibility, but I don't think it's maybe going to be worth it for a while because, you know, my implementation targets their metal microcontrollers, targets zero exception, zero allocation environments. Now, the standard version is fairly zero, pretty much zero allocation, if you want. want that. But zero exception is the standard version obviously plays nicely with exceptions.|||标准版本，而是，你知道的，我的实现。当它对你可用时，会不会有什么大的改变让你切换过去？因为我知道，你有了自己的实现，你能够以某种方式将两者合并，或者怎么样？嗯，所以我认为这并非——这并非完全不可能，但我认为在一段时间内可能不值得这么做，因为，你知道，我的实现针对的是裸机微控制器（bare metal microcontrollers），针对的是零异常、零分配的环境。现在，标准版本相当接近零，如果你想要的话，几乎是零分配。但零异常则是——标准版本显然与异常配合得很好。
And whether or not you think exceptions are, you know, well performing or whatever, the fact is, they just, a lot of bare metal, particularly bare metal things, just do not use exceptions right now. But you said, so it's not, wouldn't be worth it now? Would there be something that occurs in the future that would make it worth it? Or you're just saying for now and the future is untold? The future is untold, but I'm thinking as far as like abandoning my implementation and switching entirely to the standard, probably that's a long way in the future. Just because the way standardization works, it tends to be fairly conservative. Like what's coming into the standard with C++ plus 26 is not the full set of algorithms, for example. It's a good basis set, but there are some algorithms that aren't there.
And whether or not you think exceptions are, you know, well performing or whatever, the fact is, they just, a lot of bare metal, particularly bare metal things, just do not use exceptions right now. But you said, so it's not, wouldn't be worth it now? Would there be something that occurs in the future that would make it worth it? Or you're just saying for now and the future is untold? The future is untold, but I'm thinking as far as like abandoning my implementation and switching entirely to the standard, probably that's a long way in the future. Just because the way standardization works, it tends to be fairly conservative. Like what's coming into the standard with C++ plus 26 is not the full set of algorithms, for example. It's a good basis set, but there are some algorithms that aren't there.|||不管你认为异常是否（你知道的）性能良好或其他什么，事实是，它们——许多裸机，特别是裸机设备，现在就是不使用异常。但你刚才说，所以现在不值得这么做？未来会发生什么事情让它变得值得吗？还是你只是说目前如此，未来还未可知？未来还未可知，但就放弃我的实现并完全转向标准而言，我认为那可能还要在很久的将来。仅仅因为标准化的工作方式往往相当保守。比如随着C++26进入标准的东西并非算法的全集。它是一个很好的基础集，但有些算法并不在其中。
and also there are ways in which my implementation has diverse from some of the standard ideas. What's important to me is more that the ideas behind stood execution are sound. And I've used those as inspiration. And I've used, you know, some of the standard naming I've copied. But in many ways, I'm living in a much simpler world than the standard needs to deal. with. So that makes it correspondingly easier. Well, I mean, it's exciting nonetheless, and it's
and also there are ways in which my implementation has diverse from some of the standard ideas. What's important to me is more that the ideas behind stood execution are sound. And I've used those as inspiration. And I've used, you know, some of the standard naming I've copied. But in many ways, I'm living in a much simpler world than the standard needs to deal. with. So that makes it correspondingly easier. Well, I mean, it's exciting nonetheless, and it's|||而且我的实现也在某些方面与标准的一些理念有所不同。对我来说更重要的是，std::execution背后的理念是健全的。我把这些作为灵感。我还使用了，你知道的，我照搬了一些标准的命名。但在许多方面，我生活在一个比标准需要处理的世界简单得多的世界里。所以这相应地让事情变得更容易了。好吧，我的意思是，尽管如此，这依然令人兴奋，而且……
always, there's always new talks that are coming out. I mean, the reflection ones have already been being given. And I guess actually the senders and receivers one, there's a ton of talks like that out there. There's quite a few now from, I did, I did one, Eric did some, Steve Downey. He's done some, I think. So actually, I
always, there's always new talks that are coming out. I mean, the reflection ones have already been being given. And I guess actually the senders and receivers one, there's a ton of talks like that out there. There's quite a few now from, I did, I did one, Eric did some, Steve Downey. He's done some, I think. So actually, I|||总会有新的演讲不断涌现。我的意思是，关于反射的演讲已经一直在进行了。我想实际上关于senders and receivers的演讲，外面也有很多很多。现在已经有好几个了，我做过一个，Eric做过一些，Steve Downey。我想他也做过一些。所以实际上，我……
guess maybe it's going to be the C++ plus 29. Everyone's giving talks that are targeting the Michael Case, gave a good talk at CPP con about asynchronous handling of special function registers, I think, was the title. I'll go collect them. I mean, half of those or more have already been linked in past episodes, but I will go collect them and put them in the ones or in this episode.
guess maybe it's going to be the C++ plus 29. Everyone's giving talks that are targeting the Michael Case, gave a good talk at CPP con about asynchronous handling of special function registers, I think, was the title. I'll go collect them. I mean, half of those or more have already been linked in past episodes, but I will go collect them and put them in the ones or in this episode.|||猜想也许这将是C++29的目标。每个人都在做针对……Michael Case在CPPCon上做过一个很棒的演讲，关于特殊功能寄存器的异步处理，我想是这个标题。我去收集它们。我的意思是，其中一半或更多的内容已经在过去的节目中链接过了，但我会去收集它们并把它们放到本期节目中。
And hopefully, they're all out by now. I know the C++ now ones are all for sure and the ones that you've given. CPP con. And the CPP-con ones are starting to, or at least I think more than starting to. Most of them are now public. Although I haven't gone back and it'll be a today, later today exercise. I'll go and check to see which links that aren't linked that can be linked and update that. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com
And hopefully, they're all out by now. I know the C++ now ones are all for sure and the ones that you've given. CPP con. And the CPP-con ones are starting to, or at least I think more than starting to. Most of them are now public. Although I haven't gone back and it'll be a today, later today exercise. I'll go and check to see which links that aren't linked that can be linked and update that. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com|||希望现在它们都已经发布了。我知道C++ Now的那些肯定是全的，还有你做过的那几场。CPPCon。CPPCon的演讲也开始——或者至少我认为不仅是刚开始。它们大多数现在都已经公开了。虽然我还没有回过头去看，这将是今天、今天晚些时候的功课。我会去检查哪些链接还没有链接但可以链接并进行更新。请务必查看这些节目shownotes，无论是在您的播客应用中还是在 ADSPthepodcast.com 上
for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. I am the anti-brace. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. I am the anti-brace. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.|||这里有我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论链接，您可以在那里留下您的想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望您喜欢并度过美好的一天。我是反大括号者（anti-brace）。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。